[Music]
power doesn't stick you can try to
impose your will on other countries and
people's but without legitimacy what you
end up with is unrest instability
turmoil and the need quote-unquote for
violence to repress that turmoil we've
had for the last century in incredible
upheaval indeed I think we're still
living in the aftermath of World War one
and the Treaty of Versailles which ended
a world war one was not a treaty of
peace but a treaty of mess it gave new
imperial powers for example to the
British Empire in the Middle East and to
France and it's in those very places the
remnants of the Ottoman Empire where in
Iraq or in Syria or in Lebanon or in
Palestine now Israel we have the
continuing conflicts the settlements
that were made at the end of World War
one were settlements for European
imperial powers not settlements for
self-government not the war to end all
wars as Woodrow Wilson the US president
at the time promised the American people
in other words power rather than justice
was the message at the end of World War
one so the wars that we have in the
Middle East today were played first in
the post Ottoman Wars that Britain and
France engaged in in their new imperial
roles in the Middle East the United
States took over those empires in
essence after World War two when Britain
and France retreated from Empire the
United States expanded its military
reach Americans never like to think of
America as having an empire but Empire
means
keeping political control over others we
generally have not done it in US history
by direct ownership of other places
though we've had our colonies and still
have them but rather through
manipulating foreign governments
toppling governments we didn't like
think of Iran were in 1953 the United
States the CIA that is and British
intelligence conspired to overthrow the
elected Iranian government of Prime
Minister Mossadegh and to install a
police state under the Shah who lasted
until 1979 until the revolution came and
threw a hated despot over a despot
associated with the United States the
point is the attempt to impose rule on
others in an era of literacy
communication spreading capacity is not
only immoral but it is doomed to fail
and the United States efforts to impose
the US will in Iraq for example by
overthrowing Saddam Hussein in 2003 or
in Libya by overthrowing Muammar Qaddafi
in 2011 or the attempt remember when
President Obama said Assad must go in
Syria I scratch my head said how can an
American president say that the Syrian
President must go well we did of
President Obama issued a secret CIA
order a presidential finding that the
CIA should cooperate with Saudi Arabia
to overthrow the Syrian government that
didn't turn out too well because the
Syrian government had friends Russia
Iran which defended Assad's regime and
even though the US
they're trying to destabilize it what
happened not surprisingly was
catastrophe the flood of arms and
jihadists into that little country
violence and the flood of millions of
refugees out of the country
my response is a big duh what did you
expect when you try to overthrow a
country in the Middle East in a region
of such instability but US policymakers
often don't get it
because the instinct is were exceptional
we control we get to say who's in power
and read our our journalism The Wall
Street Journal editorial after editorial
change that regime what kind of foreign
policy is that that the United States
tells other countries what kind of
governments to have well it is a foreign
policy doomed to fail
[Music]